Hey Mike, how many times have
you heard somebody say, wow,
this was a lot harder
than i thought it'd be?
>> All the time,
I think I heard you say it this morning.
>> I think I say it a few times a week.
I mean, coding no matter how long you've
been doing it, is always difficult,
problems always come up.
>> That's true,
in reality the sign of a good developer
isn't someone who's very smart.
It's someone who's going to solving
problems and can persevere.
You're going to run into problems,
you're going to get frustrated.
There will be times you are confused.
And you're going to program yourself
into a corner that seems inescapable.
>> Whenever you run
into these situations,
it's important that you keep going.
And I don't mean keep going in
the sense that you just bang your
head against the wall, and
get more and more frustrated.
I mean going in the sense that,
day after day, little by little,
you just make some progress.
That's how you can get
through any problem.
To help out here are a few
problem-solving strategies.
First off there's sleeping on it,
seriously, it's helpful.
Take a break, come back fresh, and
you'll be surprised to find how
much easier some problems get.
You also have Google and
Stack Overflow to help out.
Most of the time your errors
are going to have messages.
Copy and
paste those messages into Google.
And you'll be surprised to
find out how quickly you
can get answers to your questions.
Stack Overflow is awesome
because people vote on answers.
So you can get a sense of
what strategy the community
thinks will solve a problem.
Seriously, this is a great strategy and
will solve lots and lots and
lots of problems for you.
But hey, speaking of community, try
asking the community, you aren't alone.
Remember, you're going to be learning
alongside a lot of other people.
Reach out and ask for help.
If you're lucky enough to know
some web developers in real life,
talk to them too.
They might be able to point
you in the right direction.
And sometimes you might need
to rethink what you're doing.
When I'm working on something
complicated, I like to draw a picture.
This picture is an actual drawing I made
the other night for an actual project.
It's not very pretty,
it's just pencil on graph paper, but
it really doesn't have to be.
Shapes, words and
arrows are often good enough.
This drawing turned out to
be super helpful for me and
wound up saving me a lot of work later.
So it's often helpful to
get your ideas on paper and
stop juggling them in your head.
You'll be able to make better decisions
if you can see the whole picture.
And lastly,
I want you to look at your mistakes and
missteps as learning opportunities.
Look at it like this,
you're never really wrong,
you just aren't right, yet.
>> That's really solid advice.
I think I've done all of those
things throughout my career.
>> Yeah, I think we all have.
I mean as you well know, the best thing
is at the end of the day, the feeling is
just absolutely incredible
when something starts to work.
We want you to keep these techniques in
mind as you work on your Nanodegree and
beyond.
>> You'll be evolving as you learn and
get better at pushing through
the problems you face.
>> To help you remember this,
I want you to write a quick
little reflection on how you'll push
through the challenges ahead of you.